[Music]
well we just [ __ ] recorded it there's
the first time I've ever articulated
this there's so many of those I should
probably call this I'm gonna call this
to 7921 run you put 80% of your energy
to squeeze instagram 150% yeah and you
spend 20% of your energy tasting YouTube
podcasts direct-mail conferences shows
but you won't be because they 80% of the
tension has to go somewhere else and
you've been tasting it on the 20% when
the 80% goes away on Instagram where the
[ __ ] do you think all this attention
goes on the [ __ ] you've been tasting
when I came out and said like snapchats
popping I've been [ __ ] tasting
snapchat for two years
I saw the Khaled moment and I look the
numbers like this is the moment but I've
been tasting it I've been tasting
LinkedIn for four years now I'm telling
people it's happening I'm still I'm
still tasting snapchat you know what you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you would sell at snapchat
I don't give a [ __ ] yeah yes I'm saying
that I'm saying you're vulnerable
because you don't have the 20% going
hard
make your 80% of the thing that's really
working the best a.k Instagram yeah go a
hundred fifty percent hard on if not 80
person everybody's doing 100% Instagram
going 70% hard got it yeah net 70 points
I'm saying go 80% on Instagram not a
hundred percent yeah go [ __ ] hard got
it go hard leaving you 20% to go hard on
Twitter and snap and all this why do I
know what's going on and snap and
LinkedIn right now cuz I've been doing
this even though I'm the [ __ ] guy
year I'm going harder than everybody
podcast email text messaging I'm [ __ ]
living over here
yeah nobody's playing here and then
everybody that's playing here is going
[ __ ] 70% so go 150 percent on the
thing that's popping yeah taste
everything else at all times
when this does [ __ ] decline yeah
you're all in here you're all in here
you've tasted on peach or you're tasted
on [ __ ] Vairo for you
tick tock You Tube snap it's all real
it's what snapchat was [ __ ] seven
years ago what if tick-tock becomes it
what if something pops tomorrow this is
the [ __ ] strategy that I roll with
that nobody else rolls with and I go
hard started with email ecommerce and
Google AdWords before social even
existed 80% was [ __ ] email 20% was
print radio Direct Mail then ad words
came ad words became 80% email was now
in the second tier then YouTube came
Wine Library TV boom then Twitter came
Twitter boom I had a million followers
on Twitter in 2009 Twitter was [ __ ]
Instagram right then it wasn't I wasn't
suggested user list and every single
person that signed up followed me but
then I was because I was [ __ ] active
and first because I'm always living in a
20% all right
LinkedIn snapchat why is it working so
well because they're organic reaches
through the roof was that when you post
on it the majority people that follow
you on LinkedIn see us yeah you've seen
that game before it's called Instagram
forty years ago
it's called Twitter seven years ago it's
called email 1997
this is [ __ ] basic this is my matrix
I'm never at the vulnerability of
anything I don't give a [ __ ] that in
that Instagram it you know many people
right now have a million followers on
Instagram but 613 on Twitter and are
silent right now sitting on their hands
and I'm [ __ ] going oh hey I'm on
Twitter I'm just busy if I was [ __ ]
actually Gary be all the time I'd be
dominating Twitter right now the last
six months I got obvious four but it's
been going on for three four years
they've been making a commitment to
content this brother it's so different
than what the source was the most
important magazine then XXL in fact
complex and vice news
content you be posting anywhere else -
you're posting on LinkedIn is this no of
course it's not no course not I'm
telling you on it let's play you can
appreciate this on Instagram it's
[ __ ] the culture I'm LinkedIn it's
business culture I'm talking to [ __ ]
people about like how to manage
organizations how to [ __ ] how to how
to like empower staff had a scale
[ __ ] marketing to b2b companies and
on Instagram I'm like yo this is 2
Chainz but sales sometimes - when I post
for empathy wines or sneakers it's like
yeah you want to look fresh in the
office yeah I don't say you want to look
fresh in the office I'm [ __ ] Instagram
me yep no but the [ __ ] fundraiser for
your next round is the [ __ ] buyer at
Nordstrom's is and the [ __ ] 43 year
old who still wants to be 17 and be
fresh definitely is who the [ __ ] do you
think could afford your [ __ ] sometimes
yeah make [ __ ] just for the LinkedIn
crowd that's 800 bucks a pop
[Music]